[Music]
hey what's up guys welcome back to
firstly feast
I'm Sean Evans and I'm joined by Andrew
ray you know him from binging madaba SH
his hugely popular Cooking Channel were
week over week he recreates dishes from
your favorite TV shows and movies then
we're going to follow SpongeBob's exact
order of assembly which starts with
lettuce on top of the burner which is a
terrible idea never did this I'm doing
this for science well today we're
flipping the script first Andrew you're
in frame sorry about that and second
we're ditching the fictitious meal theme
to instead celebrate one of America's
most traditional burger styles the smash
burger happy 4th of July everyone all
right before we begin for those who
don't know what is a smash burger well
smash burger is a burger where you sort
of make a little meatball and you put it
down in a very hot griddle and you smash
it down and get this sort of very thin
crunchy perfect little patty why in your
opinion does it have this sort of cult
following
I think the nostalgia factor is very
strong it's sort of harkens back to
these old-school diner burgers like the
ones that stopped better and brew 66 in
a car made out of wood in and out and
smash burger and Shake Shack love doing
this method and it produces a really
flavorful burger all right well before
we make our burger what do we have here
on the table what are our ingredients
well we gotta start with beef of course
and this is beef that I ground myself
that you can totally use supermarket
feed you want to get something that is
80% lean 20% fat and you have two parts
chuck this is the sort of classic burger
me one part short rib and one part
brisket this is a really flavorful fatty
combination of meat to make a really
tasty burger all right man let's make
some burgers let's do a show
so we're just gonna mix up the beef here
what people throw sauce in here and and
assault and seasoned things before
actually making the burgers you don't
want to do that now how big are you
making you want to go for like two
ounces of meat maybe like an inch and a
half across these are gonna spread out
two patties bag baby we want to keep it
about the size of our burger buns that's
a good rule of thumb just a little bit
of salt and freshly ground pepper
they're gonna be very thin so I only
want to season one side of them and this
is going to very evenly distribute the
seasoning once we squish it down so easy
you cannot [ __ ] it up try really hard I
can't
this guy's preheating I want for a
little bit of just plain vegetable oil
down means super-high heating to do that
efficiently you want to use cast iron
because you want these things to cook
and form a crust like instantly I'm
gonna hit you with a question quick
because I know that timing on the smash
burgers is crucial do you hit it right
away right over right away how does the
Burger keep its juiciness when you're
smashing down on it so thin
well it's cooking so quickly it doesn't
have the chance to expel too much
moisture and we're gonna flip them as
soon as you start seeing you see there's
like brown dark brown stuff forming here
yeah we have Maddie it's been on here
for what and then it now and it's just
about ready to flip so if you want to
really get underneath there go fast what
are you looking for in this crust to
know that it's ready to go I'm looking
for mmm a really deep brown crust and
knowing when to flip you'll start to see
the brown around the edges see it
through the holes in the patty and just
like any great diner burger we're only
going to put cheese on one patty for
each burger what kind of cheese are you
using if you want a classic diner style
burger especially a smash burger you go
in American cheese it fills all the
crevices with gooey gooey cheesiness and
these are cooking so fast you want the
cheese to melt as fast as possible if
you like blue cheese on a burger you
don't really like burgers you like blue
cheese all right they look ready to
plate let's put the finishing touches
we're starting with butter leaf lettuce
lettuce goes on first prevents and
wilting then I'm gonna throw down some
white onion on top of that now we're
gonna put patty with cheese on it
followed by the plain patty tomato next
and then we're going five pickle tips
five no more no less
last but not least we're doing little
sauce acts our special sauce with the
special sauce the special sauce is an
equal mixture of mayo ketchup yellow
mustard relish then it's got a teaspoon
each of garlic powder onion powder
turmeric and paprika I like that so
there we go
there is double burger just for your
children now that we have these plated I
have to compliment you you stack these
ingredients like a master chef how are
you able to do that here's a practice
job this is how a burger should be in my
mind however a burger should be in your
mind is how it should be for you all
right Andrew these look delicious I'm
ready to eat well it's fourth of July I
think we should go up on the roof let's
go do man's do it
everybody let's do it take a bite
[Music]
it is so nostalgic I'm eight years old
it's the summer school's out I'm just
dipping my feet off the dock just
putting them in the lake just a little
bit smashing a burger maybe I have
baseball practice in the afternoon I
don't know but who cares all I know is
this is amazing yeah it tastes like the
fourth of July yeah you know just tastes
like the summer happy fourth of July
everyone that before good don't mess
with perfection that was good that was
clean check out binging with babish it
is the most entertaining cooking channel
on YouTube check it out subscribe Andrew
thanks a lot man thank you thank you man
and I'll see you on hot ones later guys